it was a good week for New York Fashion
eyes I must say I'm pleased that the
American designers did as well as they
did it's a do-or-die situation i fear
for a lot of the littler houses the
stars are you know no huge surprises
Marc Jacobs I think was the outstanding
stars he continues to be he just takes
fashion turns it on its head and does
something provocative unusual that's
usually the antithesis of what he'd done
the season before and and Danny didn't
and again this season he didn't
disappoint last season it was about 80 s
and mud club and shoulders and neon this
is all about ruffles and pearls and a
kind of romance and theatricality that
got everybody very excited Calvin Klein
Francisco Costa did a great collection
again keeping within the difference in
mark you know Mark throws everything on
his head every time Francisco is true to
the sort of DNA of Calvin Klein it's a
much more minimalist approach but within
that he as well did a slightly softer
silhouette textured fabrics moving away
from the body much more ease and
confidence then I think he's done in the
past so he did a very strong collection
Donna Karen one of her best collections
in years again true to her own DNA oh
great looking suits appropriate for
working women done with textures subtle
colors the girls look beautiful some
unexpected stars uh Jason Wu continues
to develop as a the first lady one of
the first lady's favorite designers he
did a very sophisticated collection and
continues to grow and expand and I think
gosh Michelle Obama I could see her and
so many of the looks from that show I'll
be it a little bit longer in length
appropriately for her and then Peter
Psalm did a really nice collection he's
one of the younger generation a lot of
them had trouble this season and Peter
did a very smart short presentation
girls on a podium about 25 looks and it
was just great really great great
merchandise so I was thrilled to see
that and I think New York I think a lot
of the designers you know Oscar was true
not riveting but was consistence
consistent with what his message usually
is in the woman I was a little
disappointed Michael Kors he's
a designer of my generation we've been
around together for a long time and I
thought his collection was a little bit
out of focus he didn't really know what
he wanted to say or do and I think he
had too many trends and wasn't tight
enough wasn't wasn't a tight enough
point of view on an edit from a designer
is well established and as good as he
can be
I think the must-have item well right
now you've got to go and get a pair of
thigh high boots your boots for fall of
God abate over the knee at some point so
you wear jeans with leggings but you
need a big tall sexy kind of 70s
inspired boot a biker jacket I think a
leather biker jacket would be the piece
of clothing that everyone needs for fall
for spring that's a little too soon to
say we've only had New York London is
just finishing now we haven't had any of
the big guns in Milan or in Paris but I
would suggest that something more
romantic something feminine something
with some literally some texture to it
possibly ruffles would be something that
you needed to have for spring/summer
going forward but again a little early
to tell